[Music]
foreign
right yes we have sound so hello hello
welcome let's open the doors so
everybody in the waiting room can join
us here on daily with Doc zoom.com so if
you are watching us on a replay or one
of the live streams and you would like
to join us live you are more than
welcome to go to daily with
doczoom.com that is only available from
12 to 12 50 PM Pacific time so if you're
on the West Coast of United States that
is Pacific time if you're on the east
coast of the United States that's from 3
to 3 50 p.m and if you're in another
time zone Google is absolutely fantastic
I know doc like Siri I like Bixby Google
whatever floats your boat
we are here for you my name is Becca
Dukes I am the hostess of this program
called daily with Doc and Monday through
Friday we bring to you empowering
information
that allows you to
arm yourself so that you can make wise
choices when it comes to your own health
when we understand what's going on in
the body and why dis-ease occurs and the
solution
to being able to lessen that disease it
is amazing
at what the body can do when we take
action on the information that we are
going to be sharing with you today
I'm here because I
I tried everything
I had done everything that the medical
community had wanted me to except for
undergo the knife I was not gonna go
there figured there's got to be there's
got to be something else got to be
something else then I heard Dr Wallach
on the radio and it's like
well I've tried everything else he says
give me 90 days I gave him 90 days and
folks within the first two weeks
my thought was if getting rid of my
migraines was the only relief that I got
it was still well worth it I was going
to keep going
and it just kept getting better and
better and better
I was able to lose a hundred pounds I
was able to
no I released a hundred pounds because I
don't want to find it again
I was able to get rid of all of my pain
medications because they had pushed me
off to pain management there was nothing
else that they could do because I would
not take their surgeries and now I don't
even need surgery and I am just so very
thankful that
Dr Joel Wallach
went through all that he has gone
through and God was able to use him in
his own personal testimony and connect
him with people that got him on that
radio which is
basically the same people that I am
connected with now and I am honored to
be part of this team because we are a
team
we are here to help and build a
community that is reaching out and
touching others within their communities
so that they also can find a better
health Journey thank you Bobby that we
have with us here live an amazing
amazing audience so far and I know many
of them are some of our certified
holistic health coaches from The
Institute of holistic health that is
founded by two of the leaders within the
company youngevity which Dr Wallach is
the founder of youngevity and he's one
of the co-founders of the Institute of
holistic health
and I'm honored to be part of the staff
with the Institute of holistic health as
well just to be one of those people that
is able to use my story to touch even
more lives
and to be able to support the community
on different levels so folks if you are
here watching this program because
somebody shared it with you make sure
that you get back with them they cared
enough they took the time to share this
program with you because they know
from their experience that what you're
going to be hearing here today
is life-changing in a very good way
so without further Ado I am so very
honored as part of the daily with Doc
Peru to not only be the hostess of this
program but also
a team leader for
or and trainer within critical Health
news and daily with Doc so
Dr Wallach
let's give these people more information
in their toolboxes so that they can help
themselves and help others around them
okay as all very well said Thank you
thank you for getting it I'll give you a
proper introduction though Dr Wallach
folks if you have you have never
alcoholic or met Dr Wallach
He Man
he had a lot of stuff dropped on his
plate when he was
working his way through college in the
Pathology Lab okay that was one of his
first findings where pollution of
nitrates oh hey wait they put nitrates
in everything Dr Wallach
actually caused
500 Lambs in one night to die
because that those nitraries were
getting in their water so folks
that's just his first finding
and then he went on and he was going
around the world
he saved the White Rhino from ex from
Extinction it was on the verge of
Extinction he and his team saved the
white rhino
he has done almost a thousand a hundred
sorry almost a hundred peer-reviewed
published articles
and his thesis is Doctor of veterinary
medicine his thesis is a national
treasure in the Smithsonian Institute
which is pretty incredible Dr Wallach
that was just
it was that the second book that was
published with your name on it because
Rhino Express was at the first or was
that the second
Rhino Express
um was actually the first okay because
it took 10 years to get the information
to get the the book to send the
Smithsonian Institute okay so Rhino
Express and for those of you who are
looking for
a fun little book for your kiddos for
your young adults older children but
even younger children I think would
enjoy this Dr Wallach because this goes
through this story that Dr Wallach
um and his wife Josephine wrote in
regards to saving the White Rhino a lot
of a lot of pictures in there of the
capture methods and all that kind of
stuff a lot of a lot of action pictures
yeah it
it's a spread of them
going through you know some of the
adventures that Dr Wallach went through
as he was
working in Africa to save the white
rhino
and then
and Dr Wallach you were working at the
Reese's primate Center
and found your keys Yorkies sorry
Yorkies primate Center and with the
Reese's monkey I'll get it right see
folks you don't have to be perfect to do
this job so
I love it I love it love it
um and found the first non-human case of
quote unquote a human genetic disease
called cystic fibrosis
and you got fired
that just blows my mind that there are
associations that are primarily focused
on raising money to find a cure
and you did it and you got fired
that's correct
but it didn't stop you
because then you started teaching
nutrition at a naturopathic College
yep and went on to get your degree your
your doctorate as a naturopathic
physician
and then you took even more action in
helping the Amish community because they
had such a high occurrence of muscular
dystrophy
and you're able to to go in with Marvin
Rob who is going to be ours Our Guest
this Wednesday
um sharing more of that story
and Jerry Lewis
and Jerry's Kids I'm getting there okay
implementing nutrition into the
communities and into these children
and having doctors even confirm that the
nutrition
made a benefit can you say that it
actually took muscular dystrophy from
their bodies yes it actually cures
muscular to see and prevents muscular
see I'm not sure if she was thought to
be one of those genetic diseases okay
birth defect but it was really just a
simple nutritional deficiency disease
and it had been occurring in animals for
a long time and so I just took the
treatment they were using in a similar
disease in animals and and put it in
humans and it worked like in weeks
wow
wow so so you took that information to
Jerry Lewis who at the time was a
spokesperson for the muscular dystrophy
Association Jerry's Kids for those of
you who remember those those times I
remember I remember them as a kid Labor
Day weekend
we always watched the Telethon
and and Jerry Lewis and then he took the
information
to them and they fired him at the
Telethon they fired him and shut down
the Telethon and he had raised 2.6
billion dollars over 46 years for the
for the muscles Association they put a
gag order on him so he could not talk to
the Press
or anybody about him being fired and
that we had found this and discovered
the cost of ancient cure of muscusfie he
had a gag order on him but he died
knowing that we had found the Cure
well at least he knew in his heart
that you know they they had found it
even though
you know it's probably heartbreaking Dr
Wallach that
here he had been raising money
to find a cure for disease and then
whenever he presents it they don't want
it it sounds familiar because I got
fired for doing the same thing for
ribos
yeah so well I don't want to get fired
Dr wellick so I want to make sure that
we're providing quality information for
people meeting them where they're at and
addressing things that are affecting
them personally or those that they love
today let's talk about skin Dr Wallach
we haven't talked about skin in a while
so it's connective tissue on the outside
holds everything together
but if something's going on the outside
what do we do
okay well the skin has many many
functions
um your sweat is more than just water
okay it has antibodies in it it helps
protect you against viruses and fungus
and all kinds of bacterial infections
and things
also keeps you cool in the heat when
you're working you're exercising
um there's also
um
it's connective tissues the same stuff
that your cartilage and tendons and
ligaments are made out of
all right most people don't realize that
also it's the fertile ground that your
hair grows in
and of course there's all kinds of
reasons why we have hair in our head and
under armpits in our groin area and legs
and so forth
um there's all kinds of reasons for
having here including cooling
um fending off
bugs and stuff like that because in in
the sweat
uh glands and in the pores where your
your hair grows okay your hair follicles
um there's all kinds of stuff going on
in there to protect you against the bad
guys all the bugs okay so it's sort of
like a forest where all the good stuff
is happening to protect you against the
bad guys so here is more than just a
beauty thing but you know we've turned
it into a beauty thing uh all you lovely
ladies with your lovely hair it's a
lovely thing right but it also has a
great um thing to do with your health
and of course there's many many diseases
which doctors think are genetic
um you know we're talking about lupus or
autoimmune your body's oh it's on an
autoimmune thing your body's attacking
itself when you get and then there's
psoriasis and psoriatic arthritis which
is kind of related to lupus which is
psoriasis and brain issues you know like
um Ms multiple sclerosis in the brain
the skin psoriasis and then the bowels
you'll have irritable bowel syndrome
those three things together give you
what's called lupus thought to be an
unimmune
thing okay and it's always just nothing
but nutritional deficiencies and so
these are the sort of things that um we
got involved in and started working on
and so we also came up with uh you know
programs for all connective decisions
including the skin and then we came up
with skin products specifically for the
skin to protect the skin and give the
skin nourishment so it'll be at its best
all right
and so uh it's one of those things where
this there's see what do you call people
what do you call doctors who specialize
in take care of the skin they are
dermatologist there you go they're
dermatologist okay and that tells you
there's got to be a lot of stuff going
on with the skin for there to be a
medical specially developed this this
deals with skin issues okay that's how
important the skin is it's a medical
especially Dermatology okay
and so it's one of those things where
okay
let's get rid of all the bad foods all
the things that interrupt the absorption
of the good stuff as well as irritate
the skin no fried foods no processed
Meats we're talking about ham bacon
bologna salami pastrami pepperoni
um things like hot dogs anything with
nitrates in it okay and then no oils
we're talking about no salad dressing
cooking oils okay they cause all kinds
of inflammation and oxidation and all
kinds of stuff it puts pressure on all
connective tissues including the skin
then let's see here it's also talk about
uh let's see here
uh well when you talk about dermatitis
psoriasis these things doctors are
telling you these are unimmune things
your body's attacking itself no it's
just simple nutritional deficiencies
okay they don't get taught this in
school
and and so this is one of those things
where you're in control here because the
doctors have no earthly idea what's
going on because and they treat symptoms
they use a lot of like
cortisone
and you'll get relief
they suppress the body's natural immune
system that's correct
you're going to get some relief of all
the itching and scratching and bumps and
lumps and rashes and all that kind of
stuff and you're just so oh my gosh I
was having such a rough time my skin was
falling apart a while this doctor this
dermatologist came in all this cortisone
prednisone and and so forth and boy in
three weeks time I was a new person
within six months later they die or a
year later they die because they just
were treating the symptoms as opposed to
getting down to the basic root cause of
the problem which was obviously
life-threatening
so now this is something that we have
dealt with since the very beginning you
know
um
of youngevity we had to deal with
everything the lungs the heart the blood
vessels the liver the kidneys the
digestive system the brain the eyes the
skin
toenails fingernails uh hair You Name It
We had to deal with all these good
people every time you talk to them they
were having this question that question
and so we did an enormous amount of
research
and tracked everything down to its basic
root cause as opposed to just dealing
with symptomatic relief
we didn't want just to have some
symptomatic relief we wanted to give the
person the opportunity to prevent and
cure these issues and let them know
there wasn't something genetic that
their family or friends had to suffer
from okay
so
that's where we're coming from for the
skin thing so
um and I like to talk about
the skin requires all nutrients
okay not just vitamin D or vitamin C or
something like that I get this all the
time do you take any vitamins oh yeah
every day what do you take I take
vitamin C you take anything else no I
just been taking vitamin C for 25 years
Okay so
um
that's good the odds are if you're
taking a lot of vitamin C you're not
going to get scurvy that's what I was
thinking okay you're not going to get
scurvy yeah that's good now what about
the other 599 diseases okay uh you take
enough vitamin C you're not going to be
constipated okay that's a that's a plus
but that's not enough
but see the trouble with if you're
getting diarrhea taking too much vitamin
C you're blowing out all the other
nutrients you should be absorbing so
that's a negative okay that's not a good
thing that's a negative
um okay so here we go
um I like to per 100 pounds of body
weight take our big hammer we call it
the healthy brain and heart attack
before you go before you go into that Dr
Wallach how about just dry skin or oily
skin
their nutritional deficiencies right
they're nutritional efficiencies and
you're seeing the sort of
um symptoms of that deficiency
okay and many deficiencies will have
two three five eight ten twelve fifteen
different manifestations and you see
them you know you've got a rash here and
you got bumps here and
um
you got cracks you know behind your ears
and all the stuff going on in your skin
and it's really just a nutritional
deficiencies okay and so again get rid
of all the bad I should start out give
it all the bad stuff to maximize
absorption of the good stuff and also to
help relieve inflammation no fried foods
no processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat nobody around oats no sugar no
carbon or drinks even the dot ones got
to go in carbonated water got to go
because they neutralize stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals or digest
food
and then
um per 100 pounds of body weight when
you have a skin issue yeah it's kind of
like the red warning light in the
dashboard of your car it's more than
just a little itchy skin you got
something big going on on the inside and
you're seeing something on the outside
it's kind of like that again the red
warning line the dashboard of your car
so pay special attention any skin things
and so um none of the bad stuff which we
already said and then one healthy
Brandon hard pepper mother is 215
nutrients in the healthy Brandon hard
pack the core is still the 90s 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 minutes and
Three fatty acids I only weigh 142 but I
take two of the healthy Brandon hard
packs oh uh okay per month
um and I take a you know full dose twice
a day all right and then
um it has I say 215 nutrients
and then I also
um take the let's see here I like the
um
oh MSM I like MSM okay go ahead and take
MSM it has all the collagen in there and
things that support maintenance repair
of collagen
connective tissue
uh Carly's ligaments tendons skin that
kind of stuff and intestinal Linings and
so forth
um
the lungs everything that has any
connective tissue in it heart
bones okay and then including the skin
and then you also wanted to be taking
the collagen peptides
okay
which is the combination of collagen
from fish poultry sheep and beef okay
those four and I take um two servings of
that a day okay I want to practice one
at dinner time
and let's see here
um you know again my skin doesn't look
like a 80 year old I don't think
now it looks pretty good Doc it's not
dry it's not breaking I'll be 84. and so
this is a testimony to the how good this
stuff works and then I also uh like our
um let's see here
um
skin
Hair Skin and nails hair skin and Nails
yeah Hair Skin and Nails that's
self-explanatory I take three of those
twice a day Hair Skin and nails and it's
actually food that your skin hair nails
requires to be in maximum health and be
able to maintain and defend itself
against all kinds of outside
bad things bugs and so forth
and then also
um we also like to have an addition to
the Hair Skin and nails
I like our
um let's see here a colloidal silver
I kind of put that on my skin because it
kills bugs there's no alcohol in it so
it doesn't burn we do have hand
sanitizer if you're dealing with people
a lot like I am that everybody wants to
shake your hand and give you a hug and
patch on the head when they're taller
than you and I'll all that kind of stuff
and so we use electrical oil silver
there's no alcohol in the colloidal
silver so it doesn't burn if you have an
open wound you can put the cloth silver
on there and again
for pain we have on your skin absorbs
things and then brings it to the inside
through the lymphatics and also the
blood vessels and things
um I would also use the ultimate daily
classic tablets through the I take
through those twice today
um eligible daily classic Tales supports
healthy blood flows or blocked arteries
in the brain the heart the lungs the
skin the liver the kidneys how the
pressure goes away
um all kinds of functions that have
disappeared or pain all the bad stuff
goes away and all the good stuff starts
working again okay
and so we have all these approaches from
different directions and I do them all
that's why I'm going on 84 in two weeks
and you know I can I can duke it out
with the best of them
and the fingernails there you go
no three weeks oh three weeks okay three
weeks okay thank you you're not as old
as you thought doc okay
so so
now you were talking about colloidal
silver
and one thing that I really love about
colloidal silver and this affects the
skin around the eyes folks if you ever
get a stye
a couple drops of colloidal silver two
three times a day by the end of the day
it's almost gone
and the pain and the irritation is is
relieved quite quickly too so folks
that's that's my go-to colloidal silver
when it comes to styes for anybody any
age yeah and just for routine okay
um colloidal silver I take two of these
dropper fulls in the morning when I wake
up I take two before breakfast two
before lunch two before dinner time and
two before bedtime uh put a dropper full
under the left side of my tongue on the
right side of my tongue before you pull
the dropper out of your mouth you've
already absorbed it uh through your oral
tissues it's almost like intravenous now
this has been used as an antibiotic by
Humanity for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years long before the time
of Moses okay
so I have a question Dr Wallach you're
taking that drop or you're putting it in
your mouth is that transferring bacteria
back to into the bottle I'm
what I didn't hear that well silver
kills the bacteria
I just
I've had that question doctor in my
answer but I wanted to make it public
now here's the sick part of the medical
system now we've been using colloidal
silver for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years
no problems
1936 it came up with Penicillin and they
dumped colloidal silver like overnight
for penicillin now coil silver kills
every virus every bacteria every fungus
every
germ you can think of okay
penicillin only kills streptococcus and
staphylococcus two gram-positive
bacteria doesn't kill any viruses
doesn't kill any other bacteria or
fungus or Yeast
but yet doctors do get a prescription
fee when they write a prescription for
penicillin also
um they get an office call when you go
there because you've got to be examined
to get a prescription for antibiotic
and so they went to penicillin even
though it only only kills two
types common types of bacteria
that's it
and the thing that kills everything
colloidal silver without damaging The
Host
no alcohol in it I mean it's one of the
greatest things ever that anybody
thought of long before the time of Moses
so I have a question you're you're
killing the bacteria and the viruses and
the stuff we're using the colloidal
silver but don't you need the good
bacteria within the digestive system to
help break down the food and and make
everything happy
well the what should I say the colloidal
silver is absorbed before it gets down
into your intestine
okay so it's getting absorbed into it's
absorbing your whole tissue
okay
so I was getting into the blood system
and not necessarily being carried out
throughout the digestive system you got
it it doesn't affect the bad stuff going
on in the digestive system but what if
you've got bad stuff going on in the
digestive system what would you go to
like the killer biotic
oh yeah I I like killerman I gotta take
three of those twice a day they're small
bottles so it's a three twice a day a
killer biotic and it's actually a
um same
a little
what little toadstools okay mushrooms
mushrooms yeah a little mushrooms
different different mushrooms yeah
different mushrooms I'm like toadstools
it's a mushroom okay
and bowel movements as bowel movements
from toads
I don't think so oh okay yeah we have
mushrooms no no people strike that okay
killer biotic I take three of those
twice today and
I mean I take a lot of stuff okay uh
people come in and they look at the
what's all what's all those well I take
three of each of those twice a day plus
my
um
healthy brain and heart attack twice a
day my my Juju I also take the
um let's see here the rebound
twice a day okay and we have the sticks
we have the canister we have the cans
the cans always pop the tops and put
them in the refrigerator so the off gas
and drink them the next day kind of
thing so I'm getting 100 nutrients four
to six times a day
okay most people say oh I don't know if
I could take more than you know well one
vitamin C Taylor today okay well we'll
see who lives the longest
well and one thing that I want to point
out Dr Wallach is this is not taking the
place of food no but it's assuring that
your body is getting the nutrients that
it needs
so you don't have to worry about
accept the Good Foods bad foods list
that you can find at Daily withdoc.com
here's the ultimate question here's the
ultimate question how many minerals do
how many minerals do vegetables make
they don't make any how many minerals do
grains make
well if it's not in the soil there's not
going to be anything there but they
themselves do not make any there you go
how many minerals are made by fruit
not
okay
so
at the turn of the 20th century from
1900 to 1901
okay we had 50 new diseases obesity was
going crazy our Aries are getting
plugged we had Alzheimer's disease come
along all this stuff is just collapsing
all around us why was that that's
because
okay that's because three o'clock in the
afternoon Monday September 4th there you
go 1882 18 years before 1900
we switched from wood and coal as fuel
to electricity and doctors still don't
pay attention I I have never had a
medical doctor buy this book I have a
lot of you know our Associates and a lot
of our customers buy this book but I've
never had a medical doctor or medical
school
are you in a naturopathic College
buy one for their library and this tells
the transition from thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years of using wood coal and Fuel and
wood and coal as fuel and we would take
the ashes and put them into our Gardens
and put them into our food and spices we
got our minerals that way for all these
thousands of years and then when we
switched over to electricity uh-uh no
more wood ashes no more coal ashes no
more minerals and that's why we have all
these disease problems so this book this
tells the transition and goes through
the transition over all the time it took
for this transition okay and it's named
after this this place in New York City
where every bad thing happens okay so I
gave that same name Hell's Kitchen
because when we gave up wood and coal as
fuel
we threw ourselves under the bus because
nobody said you know we better be taking
some minerals to take the place so all
those wood ashes and coal ashes that
we're not using anymore nobody I don't
know I'm just a dumb Farm Boy from
Missouri but I figured it out
yes she did figure it out you figured
out a whole lot of stuff Dr Wallach and
that's why we are here today because you
figured out something that changed my
life gave me my life back where I was no
longer bedridden from Pain and
um I can't even pick up my toddler he
was just two years old and I I had a
hard time picking him up I couldn't even
roll out of bed myself there were there
were days so I am so thankful for this
message Dr Wall like that when you well
it wasn't you it was the people that
originally put you on the radio said hey
back up you want to have a weekly
program with Doc I'm like yes
so we did Fridays with uh stock live two
hours every Friday
and then it merged into me helping with
the daily with docs or the uh Dead
Doctors Don't Lie show that was
broadcasted on ksco and komy and whoa
and I don't know all the other channels
for 32 years for 32 years that was
fantastic and then at the beginning of
the year
radio guy said you know we got to think
of something else so we put together a
Daily Show we're streaming it I want to
thank broadcast for showing up
each and every day because that is who
brought is broadcasting this Dr Wallach
on the radio to keep the message going
for those that are listening we want to
say hi we have not gone anywhere Dr
Wallach is still alive well kicking
stronger than ever
I'm sorry mitchkin
yeah good skin
good skin his skin looks better than
mine I'm working on it he's got a few
years ahead of me on this nutrition
stuff but man
it's amazing what I was able to do in
the last seven years taking the program
um my hair shows it
it's yeah that in itself is is pretty
fantastic Dr Wallach I love it looking
good
I just want to invite all of you
to try it give us 90 days Dr Wallach you
said give me 90 days on the program that
I listen to and that 90 days has turned
into over seven years and there is no
way that I am going back
no
there's been some times where I've
backed off and I started feeling bad
again after a couple weeks and I've had
a lot of people tell me that you know
what I and I and I have a chiropractor
well he's functional medicine and
chiropractor and a whole bunch of other
alphabet soups with him he's like Becca
don't ever let me run out again
I'm like well let's get you on the auto
ship give you free shipping so we've got
him on auto ship so that he does not run
out and it has helped him with acid
reflux that he used to deal with
horrifically and just taking the healthy
body start pack Dr Wallach has helped
him with that
he's using it within his clinics
getting his patients on it he said their
adjustments are holding better he says I
don't get to see him as often but at
least they're feeling better and that's
what I'm in it for
so if you are in any type of medical
practice and you really are in it to
help your patients we encourage you to
incorporate this into your treatments of
your clients because
we're not chemical deficient
we're nutrient deficient
that's what Dr Wallach found in his
Decades of research as a pathologist
that when there were nutrients missing
there were all these different diseases
that were present yeah they would wind
up on my table dead when they were
deficient
well and you know Dr Wallach
years ago in my early 20s when when was
it before I turned 30
I was working for a medical
manufacturing facility in the quality
department and I had to learn the whole
process and I was on the returns team
and I
had to got to watch videos of surgeries
using
catheters and placing stents and when it
didn't go right
the person on that table didn't make it
off the table
breathing
and I said to myself
I want to figure out how I will never
end up on that table
because I was silently hurting I didn't
want to admit
that what looked on the outside is being
fit and doing pretty good on the inside
was screaming
and it was 15 plus years after that
before I found you
wow so I was screaming pretty loud
pretty loud
we want to give people an opportunity to
ask questions Dr Wallach okay so folks
if you are here with us on Zoom daily
with Doc zoom.com in the audience and
you have a question please feel free to
raise your hand find that raise hand
option in the zoom and let's get your
questions answered
and then if you are out especially in
YouTube because I can see I'm sorry it
looks like I'm distracted but I am very
distracted
um because we have people that are out
on YouTube asking questions I want to do
a shout out
for for
coach AJ who is out there in YouTube and
Fielding questions for us out there and
keeping the chat rolling I want to do a
shout out to Marilyn and Sherry and Ruth
Allen and all of the information that's
being shared in the chat in our live
zoom and if you want to know what's
being said in the chat if you want to be
on the live Zoom daily with Doc zoom.com
you're more than welcome to join us
again that's Monday through Friday from
12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time
so Dr Wallach I have a question for you
so I have a 72 year old
um beautiful lady she's about five foot
two
and 135 pounds
and she
um had some heart problems they went in
they placed some stints a couple weeks
later on her birthday she finds herself
back in the hospital and had suffered a
mild heart attack
so Dr Wallach what would you recommend
for her
okay well putting stents in you know can
be life-saving but it doesn't solve the
problem because the arteries were
plugged because of the diet
eating fried foods eating lots of oils
and salad dressings and that kind of
stuff causes the artery to be plugged in
the hearts and the lungs and the kidneys
and the liver and the brain and the eyes
and all that kind of stuff right
so at 135 pounds
she's right at that cuss but she's
already had uh heart stents installed
I would ever take two healthy brain and
heart pasture months if Finance is an
issue I'd ever take two Healthy Start
packs but I prefer the two healthy
Brandon hard packs take a photo of
everything twice a day I also want her
to have two bottles a month of our MSM
so you can take three of breakfast we
had lunch at dinner time and they're
going to support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue which includes the
heart valves and and the ligaments
holding the heart valves to the heart
muscles and all the artery walls and all
this kind of stuff all over the place
all right and then we also wanted to
have
um let's see here the ultimate daily
classic tablets take three of those
twice a day all the daily classic towels
take three breakfast treat lunch
okay or three breakfast three dinner
time excuse me three twice a day for her
or the ultimate daily classic tablet so
it's going to support healthy blood
pressure and healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries in the brain the eyes
the
um heart the lungs the kidneys
and it'll bring blood pressure down as
well as getting blood flow through
blotteries and I just love that product
and so this is uh she can use our
rebounders for string for energy and so
forth
um and stay away from all the bad foods
which is what caused her to have blocked
arteries it's not genetic it's not age
it's what you're eating how you're
cooking and again that's why we have the
book Dr wash cooking without the bad
foods 300 pages of safe
um recipes and also safe cooking methods
and
it has a good food bad food list in
there doctor always cooking out the bad
foods this just streams out of our
Wellness Publications just constantly
daily because it's amazing how much
information there is they're gonna add
25 to 50 healthful years of your life in
this book
thank you
yeah most definitely and folks you can
go to
drjwalik.com
that's
d-r-j Wallach like Dr J Wallick .com and
that is where you will find all of Dr
wallach's Publications he does not make
a paycheck from youngevity he recommends
the products all day long but he does
not make a paycheck from youngevity to
promote
the products he's actually removed
himself he's handed that over to his
oldest son that is now running the
business because he wanted to be able to
freely share this information without
somebody saying well you're only
recommending these because you're making
a buck off of them and folks that's not
true he does not make a paycheck I have
to pay for my own too I have to pay for
my own I don't get them for free that's
right and I've actually gone to
corporate and picked up your orders Dr
Wallach and
yeah you you yeah you eat a lot of
supplements
but anyways
um
Dr Wallach has to pay for him just like
I do just like you would you know we as
preferred customers you get a wholesale
price you save 20 off retail as a
distributor you also get the wholesale
price but the benefit of becoming a
distributor and associate with us is
that whenever you refer somebody you can
refer them to your own website and then
you get a thank you check for doing so
so that's the bonus of being a
distributor Dr Wallach and that is
something that I've been able to do
where my bonus checks are kind of nice
every month and when you say bonus
checks I mean what if they what if they
buy something every month do you get a
check from that
well we have to have our own we have to
have our own order to be able to prove
we're a product of the product we don't
make a commission on our own orders no
no no no other people's orders other
people's orders yes if you've got them
in your organization if you've sponsored
them okay and they're they're buying
every month you get a check every month
you don't just get a check when you sign
them up you get a check every month
every time
that's what you call residual income oh
that's what that means that's what that
means so every time they order folks you
are making a commission on it it's not
just their very first order
you do make a larger Commission on their
very first order but after that the
residual the reoccurring orders you
continue to make income on and it all
adds up as they are getting great
results referring others to you so that
they can also feel the difference
Becca we actually haven't you you've met
them we actually have
um Associates for our Distributors our
Associates who are high school graduates
who make more money every month than a
general practitioner medical doctor
yeah because you're out there every day
handing out their business card every
day they're they're talking to people
and getting them signed up and getting
them you know onto auto-ship and
everything like that and so their check
just keeps going up
and up yeah and you know I think it's
great Dr Wallach that part of what I do
is helping other people reach their
goals not only their health goals but
also financial goals
and it's not an overnight thing unless
you're an influencer and you have a
large following and when you say
something everybody jumps okay there's a
few people like that and I think that's
absolutely fantastic
but Dr Wallach
just like Health consistency
is what gets you to your goals and keeps
you
in that forward momentum Direction
if you only breathe one time a year
you're not gonna make it you had to
breathe consistently
yes absolutely absolutely well let's be
consistent in going to hands that are up
Dr Wallach and
let's ask the first person to unmute and
Bobby go ahead and unmute yourself
welcome to daily with Doc
well thank you Rebecca and your team
thank you for being an excellent
excellent trainer and coach we're really
proud of you and your team thank you and
Dr Wallach I have some questions for you
A lot of people are asking me how do you
sleep your skin looks so good you don't
even look in your 80s
um and a lot of people are asking that
question what's your secret and when are
you gonna get back on the road Dr wallet
we're really proud of you you're looking
so good
three weeks away from being 84 very
proud of that and of course I never had
any uh surgery I repeat that I've never
had any surgery but I've only been on
um let's see here I've been on
um prescription drugs for three days
when I had an injury of falling out into
a ditch up in Canada which wasn't
supposed to be there and at night they
didn't have lights on it and it got
punctured with rebar and they gave me IV
antibiotics for three days
other than that I've never been on a
prescription drug
and because I've been doing this since I
was nine years old
I've been doing this since I was nine
years old
20 doctors couldn't heal me in five
years my parents took me to 20 different
some were medical doctors some were
pediatrician medical doctors some are
medical doctors who are also
um
let's see here in addition being medical
doctors oh they were psychiatrists okay
and it's one of those things where
um
they said sorry we just can't you know
there's nothing we can do there's got to
be an autoimmune thing his body's
attacking itself well I haven't figured
it out when I had two and a half three
days I cured myself just by taking
bottoms and minerals now there's a long
story that goes along with that but in
two or three days I decided I'm not
going to keep doing what they're telling
me to do because it ain't working
they're going to put me in an
institution kind of like a a jail it was
a jail Hospital
and so I started just taking vitamins
and minerals for three days and it all
went away
okay so I realized and you know in
church I didn't nobody said anything so
they had gone to church after a couple
of weeks people are pointing and
whispering and pointing at me because I
was so disruptive and I you know I was
only nine years old because I'm strong
with throwing bales of hey I get beat up
an adult man who's 150 175 pounds if
they wanted to fight me I'd fight him I
only
I only weighed 110 pounds
and so so the question is Dr Wallach
when are you getting back on the road
okay uh well we're right now we're
seeing more people
um through the zooms than we did on the
road but we're we're going to start
going on the road here
in about two weeks is that correct
in January 1st we will be on the road no
June sorry June 1st will be on the road
yeah on the road again absolutely on the
road again yep yes so uh this is this is
one of those things where we cannot
thank George Nori enough for including
us in his great contact in the desert oh
my gosh
um we've been working with him for 32
years
that's fantastic I'm excited Dr Wallach
because you get to take me along with
you and I'm going to take some of our
coaching here you're a team leader and
you are going to
um you know have your team members there
because this is going to be this is a
big thing
um I'm on his radio show uh um what
every five weeks every five or six weeks
every six weeks every six weeks and he
has 125 million I want you to hear what
I just said he has 125 minute 125
million listeners
okay and so every five or six weeks I
speak to 125 million people through his
show for two hours yep
you have some people with hands up so
let's try to squeeze a couple more
questions in I know
in a go so at least get one let's get
one and Joanna go ahead and unmute
yourself
hey good day thanks for taking my call
um just wanted to comment on the topic
of Distributors I'm a distributor for
the past maybe five or 12 years or seven
years or sorry or more but I'm located
out in the Caribbean and I know you guys
like standing youngevity to have product
Distributors just distribution centers
in different areas around Australia Etc
so I'm wondering for the Caribbean
because actually to bring the products
out to the Caribbean it's so expensive
for the duties of the shipping maybe in
duties I would have to pay maybe a 30 or
30 of the cost price of the products and
our
um
our money conversion is uh maybe three
times the US Dollars
we only got a moment here so here's what
I'd recommend you connect by by texting
or emails with Rebecca okay and she can
you know connect you with our people at
youngin who we have
um shipping centers in six countries
yeah
yeah so yeah well she's been a
distributor for quite a while Dr Wallach
so I know that getting it to some
countries because of the country's
government and the duties and the taxes
that they charge does make a little bit
of cost prohibitive
in the Caribbean that is Jamaica Jamaica
Trinidad similar to the Caribbean
Islands Jamaican and those islands sure
okay well see you know I'd love to go
there and put on meetings so let's
let's just can I go about getting a
warehouse here okay so I'll leave you to
Rebecca and yourself to get with the
people that are appropriated the company
and see what we can absolutely
absolutely we definitely need some some
youngevity some 90 for life in the
Caribbean that's a that's a better price
that is like the duties arise and
shipping so that would be great
baker I'll do that
all right Joanna thank you so much for
jumping on we love the fact that we're
International
and sometimes we gotta get a little
creative when it comes to the shipping
but where there's a will there is a way
and Dr Wallach I know that you have to
get going you've got another program
coming up for those of you who have
questions and you did not get your
questions answered I do apologize
um
it's reach out to us
go to daily withdoc.com use that contact
us option I have a team that is helping
me work through all of the questions and
if we don't already have Dr wallach's
protocol for your question then we will
get it from Dr Wallach
um
I love the fact that he's accessible to
us we're not in this alone when we have
people that have specific concerns it is
individual cases he takes the time for
each and every one and I just love the
fact that Dr Wallach still does that he
doesn't have to
but he does
so again go to daily withdoc.com visit
the contact us send us a message and let
us know who you're working with if
you're already working with somebody
throw their name in there we love
name dropping when it comes to this
because with your permission then we can
share the information Dr wallach's
protocol with them as well so that they
can help you get the products that you
are being recommended if there's nobody
to think I have a team of certified
holistic health coaches who are standing
by to help and make sure that you are
getting exactly what you need we we
don't just
throw stuff in to throw stuff in we want
to make sure that you as an individual
are getting what is needed to reach your
health goals and sometimes folks
we may have a health goal
but when you're talking to the certified
holistic health coach and doing that
15-minute consultation with them
they may be able to use
the health evaluation to find out what
the true underlying cause is that's
causing you from not being able to reach
that Health goal which is what we may
think is totally unrelated
well everything within the body is
connected
everything within the body is made up of
cells every single cell requires
nutrition to be healthy
we address the body as a whole and
that's why we use holistic with the
certified holistic health coaches with a
W because we're not going to just patch
a hole we're looking at the whole body
so that the whole body can thrive
we are coming up to the end of daily
with Doc my name is Becca dukes and I am
honored to be able to bring this program
to you and it's with greater purpose
that I'm able to do it because this was
not the field that I was in yes I mean
statistics yes
and in automotive and then in medical
and then here I am after being a
full-time mom and an herbalist and all
those type of things that just led up to
me being able to actually reach my goals
as well
I want to thank Ruth Allen
we've had quite a morning today I love
technology
when it works and Marilyn thank you so
much for getting all of the information
put into the chat Sherry thank you so
much for helping with that and getting
people into the program
and making sure that we have a safe
place for everybody folks this is a safe
place if you have people that you want
to invite to this program
so that they can get the information
also that they need
to create a different Health Journey
share it we are available on YouTube and
rumble under the channel critical Health
news we are on Facebook under critical
health and if you are out
in any of those
streaming areas video land
um feel free to go to daily withdoc.com
and ask your questions there I know we
had some out on YouTube that we did not
get to
and we don't want to think that we're
ignoring you because I promise we are
not ignoring you and as far as cream
and clogged arteries
no you don't have to worry about that
oils yes
but Dr Wallach says give me cream give
me he loves heavy cream mixed in
anything and everything Dairy is not our
enemy there's some people that have
digestive issues
that'll limit their ability to have
dairy
but when we get the Bodywork what it
needs then a lot of those things go away
too and I'm proof of that so Rosella did
I forget anything
thank you
yes and there was one question on
Facebook we didn't get to either so I
wasn't ignoring you we just ran out of
time
sorry about that
all right everybody and thank you to all
of the coaches who have jumped on here
today to add more information to their
knowledge base and tools in their
toolbox so that they also can reach out
and help somebody with
those things those challenges that
they've been experiencing if you're
interested in becoming a certified
holistic health coach and coming on
board with us in this business get back
with a person that shared this program
with you if there's no one to think you
can get more information about the
certified holistic health coach course
at coachwith becca.com or
stay tuned if you're watching on YouTube
and Facebook we've got more information
there as well we'll talk to you later
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]